ليس هناك الكثير مما يمكن إنقاذه من
هذا العمل في سلوفيانسك الذي تم هدمه
صباح يوم الاثنين في غارة روسية،
أوليغ زوجته وبعض الأصدقاء يقومون
بتحميل ما تبقى، ما
زلت في حالة صدمة، ساقه القديمة، عمري 62
عامًا وقد  استثمرت قلبي
وروحي وأموالي في بنائه والآن بعد أن تقدمت في
السن تم تدميره، أدى
الهجوم إلى مقتل شخصين وإصابة
أكثر من 30 آخرين، ومن المحتمل أن يستهدف
مكتب تجنيد الجيش المجاور
في المستشفى، حيث يرقد أحد الضحايا
فاقدًا للوعي منذ 30 عامًا.  امرأة عجوز
سقط عليها جدار مما أدى إلى كسر جمجمتها
وإتلاف أعضائها الداخلية.
جراح سيرجي أوكوفيتي يكافح
منذ أن بدأت الحرب في محاولة إصلاح
الأرواح والأجساد المحطمة.
لسوء الحظ، اضطررت إلى علاج العديد من
الإصابات الخطيرة الناجمة عن الألغام
والانفجارات كما يقول.
جنوب كراسنا توركا،
وقع هجوم روسي آخر بالقرب من
روضة الأطفال هذه، ولحسن الحظ كانت فارغة منذ بدء
الحرب. تحدث مثل هذه الضربات بشكل
يومي، وقع هذا الهجوم في وقت متأخر من
مساء يوم الاثنين
بعد ساعات من قيام العمال بإجراء إصلاحات، حيث تتعرض
هذه المنطقة للقصف بانتظام، وقد
يعودون إلى هنا قريبًا  على الطريق في
كونستانتينيفيا بالقرب من الجبهة لم يبق سوى عدد
قليل من السكان تمارا البالغة من العمر 73 عامًا
لن تذهب إلى أي مكان وتضع
ثقتها في قوة أعلى
الله يحميني وتقول إن الله
سينقذني إذا لم يكن الأمر كذلك، فإن
فريقنا يبيع البذور  وغيرها من الإمدادات
لمجتمع متضائل من البستانيين المتفائلين،
الجميع خائفون، أخبرني أن
الأغبياء فقط ليسوا موجودين حتى الآن أنا هنا لكنني قمت
بإجلاء أطفالي
[موسيقى]
لم يغادر جميع الأطفال ولكن
وجد أحدهم العزاء على أرجوحة وسط
الأنقاض